so in the spirit of Hobbs and Shaw yep
we're to do a speed round because of
course the folks in London think they
have it all all figured out and we're
trying to figure out but before we do
that okay we're in Paradise yeah so can
we have a Paradise drink yes okay here
we go
let's let's have a grande bring in the
drinks we're gonna drink we're gonna
have a drink in paradise ah thank you
that's my thank you tequila assume what
I have to kill to go mine's just a
little different but I can still you
know a la Aloha mmm oh wow that's good I
didn't say okay I saw it okay all right
I know you got 12 fruits in that dress
there's a lot in there but I feel so
welcome to paradise by the way this is
unbelievable see Kevin that's what I do
right so I know I asked a lot of you you
had to go to London you had to travel
there with Vanessa Kirby of course it
Rossella Helen Mirren that fun sponge
jason statham boo now I bought you to
paradise how much better what separates
this from that why is this better now
you see how you set me up like that you
I'm gonna let you say why it's better
well I just it's not that I think it's
better it's just I think it's more
reflective of the character Hobbs in Who
I am and it's just interesting meld
between myself and Hobbs anyway and also
we wanted I wanted to change up if you
go to London then I wanted to bring you
here to Hawaii that was so beautiful and
politically correct Liana this paradigm
because it's paradise yeah what I do yes
what a Jason Statham do for you you
didn't do a thing with that thought in
mind let's play Hobbs and Chao speed
round find out about two of the toughest
guys cuz they did the same thing we're
gonna put your answers together okay
okay all right first question an
embarrassing trait about you that no one
knows Oh God when I start singing my
voice is like honey Koda gravel it's so
embarrassing
but if seeing it's so embarrassing
that's harm okay who is the bigger
softie you were statement it would have
to be me to be honest with you you know
why because I have layers of emotion
that's why
you're not just Nathan was just he's
angry that's the problem yes you don't
say Oh like you're surprised he just
doesn't go I'm a big softy I am a big
softy here's the one that's gonna be
interesting
all right who goes harder in the gym all
right listen Kevin here's the thing go
ahead right we go way back yeah and I
have to be honest with you I think that
Jason Statham actually in no uncertain
terms whatever in his entire life go
harder than me in the gym honestly we're
having an honest moment here this
moments of tequila talking yeah you have
a day with just your arms day I heard
right they're just one day I have an
arms a chest a neck day oh my god next
day all right here's a tough one because
it's it's a problem for all of us whose
head is shinier well I would probably me
because my head is bigger than his and
circumference wise it covers a lot of
ground so it's shinier but also it just
means I have a bigger brain there are a
few good jokes about that by the way in
the movie fantastic dialogue but there
are some good jokes in it big question
who would win the real fight the real
fight between me and Josh that's a tough
one
who would win the real fight that's a
tough one you know Jason is he's skilled
as a martial artist legitimately god I
love how black here you're politically
but no well here's the thing there's
always an a side and B side to my
writers right right so I give you the
truth about Jason which he is he's
masterful at what he does
his hands are like lethal very very fast
hands but who would win in a real fight
between me and Jason Statham I would
probably say I mean look I would put my
foot so far up his ass polished for a
week that's all I'm gonna say I would
rock with that alright here's the big
question who is the bigger diva without
a shadow of a doubt it's Jason Statham
okay yes definitely how much fun was it
working with Roman cliff being back here
doing something that portrayed Samoa in
essence in such a beautiful life it was
such an honor to portray one of my
cultures mysamma inside
in Hobbes and Shaw because there's not
only is it a beautiful culture that I'm
so incredibly proud of but also when it
comes to authenticity we wanted to
inject this anchor of authenticity
in Hobbes and Shaw and I wanted to we
hired all Polynesian actors yeah and one
of them is my real family and Roman
reigns and you know it was it's it's a
very very very special very special
thing by the way Roman said he was the
better football player between the two
of us yeah well that's what they always
say at Georgia Tech ha ha we beat
Georgia Tech's ass he said you had
Warren Sapp that was the dish I had
Warren Sapp we had Ray Lewis we had all
these incredible players but you know
look I'm so I got to tell you you know
this every I like I've recognized early
and I really mean it's just in terms of
an awareness of how unique this
opportunity is yes it's a spinoff from
fast and furious and the pressures on
you get one shot of a spin-off and you
hope it works if it works then there'll
be other spin-offs for other adventures
in the Fast and Furious universe if it
doesn't then the whole thing might just
get shot down right so that is a very
unique situation but they also the other
side of the unique situation was to be
able to work with with my cousin Roman
who you know at the top of the year his
leukemia came back and it was a very
scary time for him and his family
yup his wife and his kids and all of us
and for him to come back not only strong
but then come back and Hobbs and Shaw
being the first thing that he actually
came back to because we were able to
test out the waters physically and in
terms of how he would be able to do it
before he went back to the ring yeah and
but man we we came here to this island
this very Island the sacred island and
we had so much fun Kevin and and he had
so much fun and we just we toured this
place out
[Applause]
[Music]